oh
aucun doute possible
philippe manoeuvre est possédée et il a
besoin d'un exorciste souvent homme de
foi
l'exorciste et moquer parfois craint
bref il ne fait pas l'unanimité
alors l'exorcisme réalité ou supercherie
a priori quand même prendre des
précautions pour affirmer des choses
pareilles
en 1974 cet abbé été formel l'exorcisme
n'existe pas le mal la culpabilité la
mauvaiseté c'est dans le coeur de
l'homme se situe c'est pas la peine
d'aller à l'entrée du parc une espèce de
d'esprit plus ou moins bizarre l'homme
serait donc l'unique responsable ce qui
n'est pas l'avis de ce prêtre qui prend
son travail vraiment très à coeur
attention âmes sensibles s'abstenir
comme dans son qui monte vers toi
seigneur et c'est ma prière qui mangent
de la fois une séance qui a eu l'air de
fonctionner en tout cas la jeune femme
se sentait libéré après 100 d'exorcisme
inspiré soutien l'ipv6 au point qu'une
serre de nos jours la pratique de
l'exercice mais existe toujours et
rassemble comme ici en 2010 dans une
église évangélique ou les exorcismes se
font en groupe et ce pasteur est prêt à
en découdre avec le diable sarsar se
remettre dans le fait de dioila le fudge
et là le fudge et là le fait de déléguer
à l'onction de jay la touche matin satan
diable un pur je viens contre toi alors
si vous aussi vous avez le diable au
corps ne paniquez pas il fait appel à un
exorciste
avec un peu de chance ça ne devrait pas
être un enfant
[Musique]